RIGHT?
SO --
>> EITHER/OR.
I THINK PRETTY GOOD COMPANY. TO
FOR.
HANIFIN DUMPING IT  ETHAN BEAR.
HE TOOK THE SKATE.
SUFFERING AN  AWAY.
MARKSTROM, HAD A LITTLE TROUBLE
WITH THAT BUT ABLE TO STEER THAT
I'M SO
IMPRESSED WITH HURNS THAT TO TH
CORNER FOR ANDERSEN.
NOW MONAHAN. LINE.
WHAT A SWEET PASS FROM AHO
12th.
EIGHT POINTS IN LAST THREE GAMES
>> Kelly: THE FACT OF THE MATTE
SHOT AND CHANCE TO TIE I's GOAL.
AT THE 4:14 E.
GREAT PLAY BY MANGIAPANE.
GET IN FRONT TO COLEM BLUE LINE
STRIPPED OFF HIM.
JIENGT BEAUTIFUL
BACK TO THE LINE FOR SKJEI.
BLOCKED B B LINDHOLM AND
CLEARS.ANES BRING THE PUCK BACK
TH IT ACROSS.
LINDHOLM SKATES TO CENTRE.
NOW GAUDREAU TRYING TO GET IN.
KNOCKED OFF THE STICK AT THE  G
>> WE TALKED ALMOST AS EQUALLY A
GOOD CHANCE TO
TROCHECK FINDS SVECHNIKOV.
BACK TO THE LINE TO SLAVIN.N. T
DEFENCEMEN.
AND IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE A PO
ANDERSSON AND LITTLE
TRAFFIC AND WHAT LOOKEDK ON ND L
NIEDERREITER, KNOCKED DOWN WITH
PHYSICAL PLAY BEHIND THE NET BY
BOUNCED OUT TO CENTRE.
TKACHUK COULDN'T TAKE IT BUT
GOES BACK TO ANDERSSON.
NOW HANIFIN. CHAOS ON THE LAST
SHIFT.
FACE-OFF JUST OUTSIDE THE
CAROLINA ZONE.
>> Kelly: SO IT WILL BE GAUDREA
ANDERSSON.
STAAL, SLAVIN AND SKJEI. RIGHT?
>> Rick: SMART PLAY.
FINAL MINUTE OF PLAY IN
OVERTIME.